players who are remembered for the wrong
thing and i've got a trivia question for
you big cat if you get this wrong you
should hang your head in shame for the
entire weekend because even i
knew this one the cubs traded bill
buckner to the boston red sox for which
hall of fame pitcher
uh
that would be
denner's dennis eckersley right damn it
i was good i was gonna say i had my
years because i was like because the
cubs obviously traded greg maddox too
who's in the hall of fame but that was
much later
uh yeah
[Music]
yep you guys first i miss baseball i
wish we had baseball
uh okay all right my first pick this
one's easy for me uh i will go with
gary anderson
damn it
gary anderson
fantastic career
all decade team 1980 80s all decade team
1990s
uh you know 23 years in the nfl
led the league
in percentage for field goals in that
1998 season what was his percentage
he didn't miss a single one now 100
and then he missed this
and this was to go to the super bowl the
15-1 vikings
uh and then we remember gary anderson
who had a fantastic career for that one
big miss oh my god that was unfortunate
now the vikings were up by seven points
at the time that would have put them up
by 10 without nearly enough time for the
falcons to close the gap they drove down
the field they forced overtime and then
they won the game in overtime thank you
i have a feeling that that that that
idea was fed to you by someone but it
was at the top of my list gary anderson
what a way to be remembered all right
next one for me and and look i
actually this guy is remembered for two
things
rather than his dominant play as a
defensive lineman it's leon lett
formerly the dallas cowboys he had the
incident on thanksgiving day against the
miami dolphins when all of the sleep was
on the field at texas stadium that was
an nbc game where he touched the ball
after the block field goal allowing the
dolphins to recover and keep possession
and win the game and who can forget
super bowl 28 i believe it was when he
was running in the uh the turnover and
uh it was don beebe who came up from
behind him and knocked the ball out i
won some money on that i had one of
those things with the square where you
match up the
the the second number for the team
scores if that touchdown counts i would
have lost like 250 bucks but there's the
the original do you see jerry jones in
that shot so good so good i don't
remember that part but that's so funny
and there goes leon lead it was the
fumble by jim kelly and off goes
leonlette to the races and uh he got a
little cocky a little little fancy dan
at the end don beebe not giving up even
though the game was over uh knocks the
ball out and uh goes out of the end zone
touch back bills dumbest rule in
football but great hustle by don beebe
and that's how we know leon led all
right you're next well done good one the
b-roll since we didn't give them these
in advance
yep or did you give them to
you probably all these answers all right
uh my next one will be ernest biner
ernest biner the fumble the the browns
fans obviously will never forget this
this this is the fumble against the
broncos the afc championship game ernest
biner goes on to win two super bowls he
went to two pro bowls he was fantastic
for those redskins teams so uh he gets
remembered for the fumble with the
browns
not for winning super bowls with the
redskins ernest biner is my second pick
and it is a fantastic pick if i may say
so myself
that that is a great pick very well done
and you're right a guy when you hear
that name that is what you think of and
look i hate to do this to one of our nbc
colleagues but it's a fact rodney
harrison right potential hall of fame
career patriots hall of famer but he
will be forever linked to that david
tyree helmet catch from super bowl 42
that derailed what would have been a
19-0 season now there's a caveat to this
there's another guy who should be even
more notorious in that play not that
play but that drive asante samuel had an
interception in his hands just a few
plays earlier that would have ended the
game and it squirted right through
proving yet again that's why he plays
defense but yeah rodney harrison a great
career and this is just one of those
crap happens plays there wasn't anything
he could have done differently it just
was the hand of god reaching down just
like we talked about earlier omnipotence
rolls in and sticks that ball to the
helmet of david tyree roddy doing
everything he can to knock it out the
ball doesn't touch the ground but wrong
place at the worst possible time for
rodney and there will be people who
remember him for that when they should
be remembering him for a an incredible
career on the field as one of the best
defenders of his generation
okay i'm gonna go with my last pick
something a little different so we've
been doing uh specific plays
i'm gonna go with a career
i'm gonna say
dan marino
remembered for not winning a super bowl
when he should be remembered for being
one of the greatest quarterbacks of all
time and as time goes by and you say oh
yeah dan marino doesn't have a super
bowl that narrative keeps getting
written so that is a maybe my best draft
ever a fantastic draft a fantastic way
to win uh right before memorial day
which dan marino didn't do see i did it
right there i didn't even mean to do it
but i did it because he never won a
super bowl but that is what he's
remembered as when he should be
remembered as one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time
dang i really did well here that would i
still have one more pick i still have
one more pick how can you declare
victory when i have a pick left
because you it doesn't matter what you
pick i've won the game the clock has hit
zeros
i uh we actually have five more minutes
in this segment although we don't have
to use them all
i we can go another round if you if you
if you're feeling if you're feeling uh
you know good about yourself and you've
been out you're wondering
you're out you emptied the tank you bet
you better you need to have somebody
else feed you a fourth one or you're
going to be in trouble
i will go
i will go with jim marshall the former
vikings defensive lineman who should be
in the hall of fame he had the all-time
iron man streak before brett favre got
there he's known there it is
well done control room
see this here's what he's known for he's
running the wrong way
jim marshall scoops up the fumble that
was a game that had like 13 total
turnovers he runs the wrong way into his
own end zone throws the ball into the
crowd for a safety for uh the san
francisco 49ers billy kilmer on the
fumble he was playing running back for
the 49ers at the time what that's a
great that's a great pick i just the
other day i was talking to
everyone about jim marshall running the
wrong way
true football fans know about jim marsh
true football fans know about jim
marshall running the wrong okay true
football fans know about that here's mr
teddy roosevelt man in the arena
bullcrap yes okay i have some honorable
mentions i'll throw out there i was
going to take another pick take another
round take another round
oh you don't want to undermine your
horrible incredible pick all right no it
is the perfect draft um honorable
mentions
t.o
t.o remembered for his antics off the
field for the you know the sit-ups in
the driveway he was one of the greatest
receivers of all time he's on there for
me
kevin dyson
and that titans team in general falling
one yard short and that's what they're
remembered for that the air mcnair
offense and and going 13-3 and having a
fantastic you know uh season and
upsetting the jaguars in the afc
championship game what
kevin dyson just two or three weeks
before maybe four weeks before
he he he came up a yard short of forcing
overtime potentially in super bowls
he's the music city miracle that's what
everyone remembers k you know the titans
falling one yard short there
here's here's our buddy frank wycheck it
uh still looks man from that angle it
looks like a forward pass although he
shares it wasn't there goes kevin dyson
hey kevin dyson was the receiver taken
in 1998 before randy moss by the way wow
wow that also jeff fisher told us that
kevin dyson wasn't supposed to be the
guy there uh it was actually i think
someone got hurt and that's why he lined
up so incorrectly and why it was so
close to being a forward pass because
that was not the usual guy who gets the
ball there
who else you have on your list anyone i
got scott norwood scott i didn't want to
use scott norwood as a pick because you
already did the kicker well also scott
norwood i looked at scott norwood um and
his career wasn't exceptional like gary
anderson who missed that kick in the nfc
championship game against the falcons uh
when the vikings were 15 and one so i i
discounted him for that
i also had new o'donnell on there not
that neil o'donnell had a great career
but he is remembered
for the two interceptions thrown
directly to larry brown in super bowl 30
and again he wasn't a great quarterback
and he went to the jets after that game
and uh proved that he wasn't a great
quarterback but he had promise and he
was on the upward swing who knows maybe
one of the reasons why he stunk for the
jets is he was scarred by what he did in
super bowl xxx i also had jake dalome on
there because i'll tell you what even
though jake dillon had a great career
took a team to a super bowl i can't get
past that that playoff game against the
cardinals in 2008 when he just he just
imploded to me that's what i think of
when i think of jake delon
yeah jake talom that was a tough one um
bad yeah that that playoff game was was
something else it was actually shades of
dan marino against jaguars his last
playoff game when i think the jaguars
scored like 70 points or whatever it
ended up being it was like
61-7 or something it was obscene we'll
get that score
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports